thanks for having me
I'd like to talk today about some of the
work I finished up my PhD at NYU on and
that was with Rob Fergus there and this
started off what is now clarify I new
start up here in New York specializing
and image and video recognition so as an
overview I'm going to describe a
technique to visualize convolutional
networks and convolutional networks are
a way to recognize objects in images and
video and what we use to do this is
something called a d-- convolutional
network and I'll get into that in a bit
so with this visualization we can
actually understand what each layer is
learning now and from that gained some
insights to improve performance so what
are these models convolutional neural
networks so they're not new they've been
around since around 89 by this fellow
yan Lacan who is a professor at NYU and
he's setting up the AI group at Facebook
now and he came up with the idea to
apply neural networks over small regions
using a convolution instead of over an
entire image using a fully connected
layer so it looks something like it's
shown on the bottom where you have
convolution layers you have some
non-linearity it just allows the model
to learn more robust functions than
linear functions and a pooling layer
which is typically max pooling these
days you could do things like average
pooling as well so that process of
convolving taking non-linearity and
pooling is repeated several times until
basically the spatial information is
pooled out of the image and you get a
final output layer that gives you a
probability over all the categories
you're interested in recognizing and
this is all trained by back propagating
your classification error so when you
make a mistake that error is back
propagated throughout the entire network
to update the / M
in a real example when you show it an
image you would do convolutions pooling
and repeat that I didn't show
nonlinearities but the probability would
be something like that where it's highly
confident there's a boat in this image
and less likely that there's dog a cat
or a bird and there was really a bunch
of pioneers in the field two notable
ones were Yan Lacan and Geoff Hinton and
this these ideas behind neural networks
have been around since the 80s when
these guys started working on them
and even before that into the seventies
and the the new approaches that are
giving breakthrough performance numbers
have very much the same architecture as
was around in the 1980's the main
difference was around 2009 when GPU
computing became mainstream and applied
to machine learning we could get a
thirty times speed up and I was crucial
for allowing us to train on much more
data and much bigger models and when you
do that
you can make them all as much more
powerful and understand a lot more about
the world it also helped with
experimentation because we could iterate
on experiments much quicker and the big
companies have noticed this so Geoff
Hinton was acquired by Google
he had a small start-up recently
acquired about two years ago and yanma
Khan is now heading up the AI group at
Facebook since last December and the
results that were really a breakthrough
in this field were by geoff hinton
and that's why google acquired them
quickly after these results is by two of
his excellence PhD students Alex
Khrushchev ski and alias at skevur and
they did something like this so I'm
showing here error rates on a common
benchmark called imagenet which is held
every year and the benchmark is to
recognize out of a thousand different
categories which objects appear in an
image and you're given a training set of
about 1.3 million images a held-out
validation set for 50 thousand images
that you can play with and
a Soria held a test set up a hundred
thousand images that you never get to
see the labels for so it's a fair
comparison in that sense and the four
bars to the right are traditional
computer vision methods and the goal
here is is to minimize the error rate
and you can see the supervision team out
of Toronto use a deep neural network
instead of a traditional computer vision
method and it was basically a step
function in terms of performance
dropping by ten percent instead of
twenty six it's down to about fifteen
percent so this is a revolutionary
result that has really changed the whole
field of computer vision and many people
in that field have now switched to using
neural networks in their research
another nice result that recently came
out was this group out of MIT that
compared the performance of these deep
neural networks to that of a primate and
a human and they did that by creating a
data set like shown on the top with ten
images or ten categories of objects put
on top of random backgrounds with
different scales and rotations of the
objects and then they were presented to
a monkey and they actually opened up the
monkey's brain and implanted electrodes
and when they were presented with the
objects or the images then the
electrodes would fire in some certain
pattern those were recorded and then a
simple linear classifier like an SVM was
trained on top and the goal was to see
if from these electrode firings you
could actually recognize these objects
and they compared that to some of the
deep neural networks and also humans so
here is the monkeys v4 layer so the
visual cortex is thought to be
decomposed into layers this is some
intermediate representation so using
that you can get about 40% accuracy with
extrapolation the extrapolation is
because they only recorded about 300
electrodes whereas there's billions of
neurons
or more that they could have recorded so
they extrapolate a bit looking at IT
Corps Texas is much deeper into the
brain and has a lot more reasoning
involved about the objects and the scene
and you can see the massive important
performance boost and it's nearly 75
percent so then they compared to humans
on Mechanical Turk presented with the
same images and a key thing here was
they're presented for 100 milliseconds
and any one of us in this room who saw
these images for more than that would be
able to get nearly 100% but in a rapid
presentation you're only using a certain
part of your brain that can do a feed
forward pass which is very similar to
these neural networks and you can't do a
lot of reasoning so the performance is
not quite as good nearly that of the IT
cortex of the monkey then they started
comparing machine learning and computer
vision models so v1 like models are
basically edge detection at different
orientations at different frequencies an
h max model combines that with some
pooling so that you don't really care
exactly where these edges are in the
image it's a little bit invariant to
that model out of the Google brain group
this was trained without any labels to
learn some interesting features and then
applied to the classification task
I didn't perform that much better and
then this is the Toronto group's result
that one imagenet competition so you can
see a massive boost performance actually
surpassing the monkey at this point and
then this was Rob Ferguson I out of NYU
and this is showing that these models
now are actually at the performance of
not only monkeys but actually humans
when you're presented with images in a
rapid pace and the nice thing about this
is when these models are run on GPUs you
can actually run them significantly
faster than 100 mils
Ekans so we can actually perform at
human levels and do it faster but with
all these nice results it's not really
clear what these models are learning so
that's what Rob Ferguson I really wanted
to solve and dive into so we did that
using a technique called D convolutional
networks and this is something that Rob
and I did for the first few years of my
PhD and the goal of that project was to
create an unsupervised learning model so
we didn't care about labels we just took
the image as the input and tried to
reconstruct it while making the
top-level feature is very sparse so
using very little of them and it was a
completely top-down model in order to do
that reconstruction and it was an
inference method like sparse coding to
kind of infer these features that
reconstruct the image well and are
sparse and we used all the same
components as convolutional networks
we used convolutions but using a
transpose of the filters we use
nonlinearities and we use done pooling
which I'll describe next and in this in
this work where we visualize we oh we
don't do any of the optimization we
basically use this as a tool to just
look into a convolutional networks
features and then reconstruct them down
to the image so one important part could
get this reconstruction very clean and
sharp is to make the max pooling
operation that you have in convolutional
networks to be reversible so when you're
going up in a convolutional Network you
have something like this where there's a
bunch of activations longer bars are
stronger and smaller or weaker and you
usually do pooling over local regions
say two by two so doing max pooling you
get something like this where you keep
the strongest element and you can do it
with or without keeping the sine in this
case we're keeping the sine taking the
strongest absolute value and what we
also do in order to reverse this is
store where that value came from
we call that the switches and that
allows us to take any new value that
we're using during the reconstruction
and plop it down in the correct location
and setting up all the other locations
to zero this is really important for
getting good reconstructions especially
when you have multiple layers because if
you arbitrarily pick a location you're
really losing all the edge information
in the image so that really makes the
image that you're reconstructing blurry
and you actually get a lot of different
color variations as well so if we look
at what these models are learning
starting at the first layer you see
something like this so we're looking at
a convolutional neural networks first
layer filters so these are what are
involved directly with the pixels and
you can see it's a bunch of oriented
edges this is what people find in
individual cortex actually in be one
type of layers and you can also see
color logs and color edges at different
frequencies and different orientations
so this is nothing new people knew that
these these models and many other models
learn the same type of features from
pixels but it's just showing you what it
looks like but nobody really knew what
was going on above that so to do that we
want to project from the higher layers
back down to get some visualization what
those higher layers are doing so what we
do is we take an input image we run it
through the convolutional Network
feed-forward that gives us some
activation over all the feature Maps at
whatever layer we want to visualize this
could be the third layer for example and
to visualize them we select the single
feature map at a time that we want to
look at and we take the strongest
activation in that feature map for that
image and that gives us an idea of what
part of the image and what any image
actually activates that feature really
strongly and we use that as input to the
top of addy convolutional network that
uses the same filters from the
convolutional network and also the same
switches from all
max cooling layers in the convolutional
Network in order to reconstruct top-down
to give us a visualization so it's
really crucial that you use the same
filters use the same switches and take a
strong activation we don't just look at
a strong activation for one image we
want to see what this feature fires on
through a bunch of images to learn or
only what most strongly activates it
over a whole data set but also how it's
invariant by looking at a set of these
strong activations so we run it through
a validation set of 50,000 images and we
take the max activation for each of the
feature maps over the entire 50,000
instantiations of it and that gives us
the strongest activation that we
visualize downwards using the switches
for the image that that activation came
from and we look at the second strongest
activation out of all 50,000 images the
third fourth and we'll show you up to
nine of the strongest activation and
you'll see how that can show some type
of invariance that that feature has
learned
so what I'm showing here is looking at
the strongest activation in the first
layer feature maps and the colourful
plot is patches out of the image these
are pixels out of the image right above
where that activation fired strongly and
they correspond to the filters that are
shown in the bottom left so if you look
at the top left filter here it's almost
horizontal and you can see the top left
3x3 region here are all patches of
horizontal type of content with
different colors and the top left of
that 3x3 is a strongest activation
throughout the entire 50,000 images and
all the spatial parts of the images for
that one filter and then the second row
first column is the second most strong
activation out of the entire data set
and so forth all the way to nine
strongest and you can see for comparing
the patches to the filters it's doing
what you expect it's firing on when
those pixels line up to how the filters
look like and same with the colors you
can see it lining up not always in an
obvious way but in some way either
positively or negatively correlated with
the colors of the filters now it gets
more interesting when we go to layer two
so this is something that wasn't obvious
what was happening everyone could look
at the broad coefficients in layer 2 or
the raw coefficients in layer 1 but
before this they haven't really seen
what's going on in the second layer and
you can see it's learning a much more
complex set of patterns than the first
layer edges and you can see it's
combining them in meaningful ways like
parallel lines curves circles
t-junctions grading patterns colorful
blogs a huge variety of different
structure is present and already the
second layer and you can see it covers a
much larger space of the image because
it's gone through the first layer
convolutions then there is a pooling
layer in between the sec
convolutions so it has a much broader
scope of what I can see in the image and
that's represented when we reconstruct
down we get a larger reconstruction
that's right above where the strongest
activation in the second layer occurred
now this is showing all of the 256
different feature maps in the second
layer so this is giving you the
strongest activation for each one of
those but we can also look at a handful
of randomly selected ones that are
showing that not just the strongest
activation by the nine strongest
activations and you can see that it's
exhibiting the same type of grouping
behavior that you saw in the first layer
but it's getting more complicated at
grouping so you can see because of the
pooling in the first layer after the
first layer convolutions these features
are are pretty invariant to small
changes you can see down here that a
small dot and a circle and spiral all
fire the same second layer feature very
strongly and you can see even here texts
like features or strong grid patterns
fire that feature and it can be
invariance to different orientations can
be invariance to the tightness of
circles different colors there's a bunch
of different invariance that's already
encoded by second layer now looking at
these is hard to tell what something
like this might represent in the image
but what we can do because we know the
exact location of where we start the
reconstruction from and all the pooling
switches going down we can crop out the
part of the image where that came from
if you flick back and forth you can see
that these purple like regions are
actually skin color so by the second
layer it's determined that skin is
actually really useful to have as a
feature
just below that a slightly brighter red
type of shade is actually some kind of
fiery looking thing you can see other
grouping like circles over here or the
circles down there blue type of patterns
so this grouping by color or by shape
moving to the third layer it's getting
more and more complex so this is now
gone through to pooling layers and three
convolution layers so it's seeing about
80 by 80 pixels in the original image
which was around 224 pixels and now you
can see it starting to learn object
parts things that are important for
building up a representation of an
object you can see in the top left
things like a dog's face a human face
eyeballs a baby's face some texture
regions you can see it's again much more
complex than what the second layer was
we can do the same type of examination
of the nine strongest activation and
there's a lot of grouping as well but
it's more grouping not at the very low
level edge type of information but more
semantically relevant things like
people's faces or different types of
grid patterns but not all the same type
or even this one up here which has a
strong green tinge to it if you look at
the patches that correspond to that it's
grouping fire together
if we look at the bottom middle region
it's kind of hard to see what this is
from the visualizations but if you look
at the patches it's learning a cloud
detector essentially and even categories
that a visual content that aren't actual
categories in the tasks such as grass is
actually being learned as a strong
feature by the third layer moving to the
fourth layer same story applies this
time there was no pooling between the
third and fourth layer so the size of
the receptive field that the fourth
layer sees in the image has not grown
that much but the content is getting
more and more object specific you get a
lot more fully formed faces of dogs and
humans and other large object parts if
you look at the nine strongest here the
groupings now are almost not at all
structurally related but more
semantically related for example the
pose of these dogs is not exactly
overlapping anymore but you can see that
this whole feature just fires on dogs of
different breeds this feature blow into
the right is firing on a variety of
different eyeballs I think they're all
dogs but the feature up and to the right
it's firing on a combination of dogs and
monkeys that have very similar phases
one other interesting one in the fourth
layer is the bottom middle where you see
these strong green activations this is
actually small green locations in the
image and before doing these
visualizations we never thought that
would be something that the model thinks
is important we thought color would be
washed out very early on or be a very
blurry feature but it's really
localizing exactly where that feature in
the image is and it's kind of incredible
that it can do that all the way up
through multiple pooling layers multiple
convolution layers and we didn't expect
that the final convolution layer is 1/5
it again did not go through any
additional pooling layers but it's
getting slightly larger because of
boundary effects on the convolutions and
it's getting closer to the
classification layer which is still
another couple fully connected layers on
top of this and because it's getting
closer to having to make that decision
on what class the image belongs to the
content in this layer is getting more
and more object specific if you look at
the the breakout here just below the
number 5 you can see a bunch of
interesting patterns and those are
actually keyboards of different types at
different orientation that's something
again we didn't expect to see is
rotation in bearings these models don't
have any explicit rotation appearance
they have a lot of shift invariants
because of the convolutions and the
pooling there's no explicit way to
represent rotation but one way you can
actually do that representation is using
max pooling locations by taking if you
consider the local regions you can move
a max pooling location a couple pixels
over and then a couple pictures to the
right and then down and to the left and
it'll give you some rotation invariants
very locally and as you do this at
higher and higher layers you can encode
that in the model another interesting
feature in this layer is right next to
the keyboards there's some hazy looking
blog that's actually a background water
detector and water itself is not a
category I believe but it's important
for doing things like recognizing seals
or bathing suits or ships
and finally another interesting one here
on the right is all these dogs it's
actually learned basically a husky
detector by the fifth layer and there's
only 256 features in this layer but it's
realized that that is unique enough and
important enough to have that it
basically allocated that representation
for that feature and again nobody's done
this kind of allocation this is all
learned by the model so another
experiment we did before actually doing
the crops of out of the image we just
looked at the visualizations before
doing this experiment we want to confirm
the visualizations were actually
triggering on parts of the image that
makes sense so what we did is take a
block of zeros essentially and actually
the mean pixel 128 and run that over the
image and at every location of that
block we recorded certain parts of the
activations or the probabilities of the
model so for example on this image we
took the great block and slid it over
and on the bottom left for showing the
probability of Pomeranian which was a
true label assigned to this image and
each pixel of that bottom left figure is
a location of block over the image and
you can see when the block is over the
face of the Pomeranian the probability
of Pomeranian significantly drops
basically the zero and at that same
instance what we're showing on the right
is what is the most probable class out
of a thousand and at that time when the
block is blocking the face then the most
probable thing it's guessing is tennis
ball which is a reasonable guess if you
consider blocking out this region so you
can see it's really localized on the
face and finds that important for
recognizing this category and the reason
we picked this image is because out of
the visualizations it was one of the
strongest ones that fired one of the
fifth
err features so when we look at that
feature map as we as we slide the block
over the image we can look at the
activations and how strongly that that
feature fires you can see that because
the visualization showed us that it's
triggering on the face of these animals
it dropped significantly when we cover
the face so it's kind of confirming that
the way we select the visualization is
actually showing us what we're we're
expecting to see a different example
this is a true label as a car wheel it
could be many things but when the car
wheel is blocked out you can see the
probability drop significantly saying
that the models really localizing where
the car wheel is and the most probable
class is kind of scattered because
there's many things you could label this
image but an interesting thing we saw is
that the strongest feature that we
looked at was the one with the number
880 AC and that came from this image as
you can see but when we block out any
text in the image it's actually dropping
that feature significantly so it's
giving you some notion that be the fifth
layer has learned a text detector you
can see from the other features that are
visualized here not from this given
image but from other images it's firing
on all kinds of text different languages
even or different fonts different colors
different orientations so this is really
interesting because text is not a
category in the model but it's learned
that when you recognize text it can
associate with other classes and another
interesting one is this example which
was labeled Afghan hound and when you
block out any part of the dog then it
obviously drops the probability of
Afghan hound but when you block out the
faces it actually increases the
probability of the hound
so it's showing you that there's some
competition here over the what is the
true label in this image and if you
block out either of the faces it's more
confident that
it's an Afghan hound and you can see it
jumps around all over the place and when
it jumps it actually goes to a lot of
categories so faces is not a category in
the thousand but there's a lot of things
that are really associated with faces
like fur coat or mortarboard or academic
gown or neck brace that always come up
when you show people's faces and
especially when you block out the dog
and that's actually one of the features
in the fifth layer is faces that is
really invariant to the type of face or
gender of the person and you can see it
firing or localizing exactly where those
faces are so this shows you kind of what
is being learned in all these layers but
now how can we use this to actually
improve the performance of the system so
we took the Toronto group's model which
one the image net challenge in 2012 and
we visualized it and what we saw right
away is on figure a here we saw a huge
disparity between the normalization of
the filters in the first layer you can
see one really bright white one a bunch
of very dark ones that do have some
structure but they're just normalized
completely differently so we notice that
we do need to do some kind of
renormalization in order to to fix this
problem and help all the features learn
the same so we looked after we fix that
we looked at what they're learning now
and you can see very specific filters so
very high frequency structured data and
also a lot of dead filters so we weren't
sure why that was but it what our guess
was that the filters were too large for
this first layer because they chose to
use 11 by 11 filters and that can
capture a large part of the content of
the image when you look at 11 by
Patch's visualizing the second layer we
also saw a huge amount of blocking
artifacts so this was a key a key
finding because we notice that it's
losing a lot of information here and you
can see that as well by having a lot of
very simple second layer features so
what we did was we we renormalized the
first layer filters so that they would
never go outside some threshold of root
mean squared values and that makes all
of them kind of compete evenly with each
other and that gave us figure B here
then to fix the very specific filters we
just made them smaller instead of 11 by
11 we look used seven by seven that
keeps them a lot simpler but you can
still see it's learning a huge variety
of content different colors different
orientations and frequencies and to help
with the blocking artifacts and make the
second layer much more useful we made
the strides in the convolutions which
are how often you apply this filter in
the first layer we move that from four
to two and then completely remove the
blocking artifacts and also allowed the
second layer to be a lot more flexible
and learn much more interesting content
so that helped us win 2013 imagenet
competition you can see the results from
the Toronto group on the far right it
was around sixteen point four and then
there was a bunch of different entries
some from large companies some from
other startups some from top research
institutes around the world the CF entry
was Ashley Rob and I out of NYU and then
the clarify entry was me starting up the
company and
there's kind of two entries one just
with the original training set and the
other with a little bit of extra data
also from imagenet but different
categories so these same tricks that we
use to reduce the stride and the size of
the filters also were used in this
year's competition to give very good
results actually all of the groups move
to this approach and the top five at
least and even smaller filters were used
to get really good results that got
second place in classification and first
in localizing where the objects are and
also Andrew Howard had some interesting
results using much smaller filters and
smaller strides and even the
visualizations have been reused for
determining salience E because if you
look at where the visualizations are
firing they were not always covering the
entire object they weren't necessarily
useful for detecting a bounding box
around an object but they were useful
for understanding what part of that
object is used in the network to
recognize it such as the Pomeranians
face so if you wanted to get a
pomeranian bounding box it wouldn't be
very useful but for finding the saliency
of Pomeranians you can use the same
technique and the last thing we wanted
to look at was how well do these
features generalize
so we took a model trained on imagenet
which has a million images are 1.3
million images and applied it to a
different data set called Caltech 256
and that has less categories 256 of them
some of them are overlapping some of
them are not and the previous state of
the art was something these two results
shown in green and red and the top end
was around 55% so what we looked at is
taking this pre trained model the
filters and all the layers learned on
imagenet what we could do with very few
number of training examples and with
only six examples we're actually
matching the state of the art so it's
showing that these models really thrive
when there's lots of training data and
they learn features that are important
in general for object recognition and
then it could be transferred to other
tasks and other datasets very easily
with very few new examples and you can
see when you do have lots of new
examples they significantly outperform
what you can do if you train on a small
number of examples alone in table format
you can see the previous two results
weren't going up to about 55% if you
just try and train on the Caltech 256
data set with an image net size model
large convolutional Network then it
really struggles it can't actually learn
the features properly because it's just
not enough examples these models have
somewhere near 60 million or 70 million
parameters and the Caltech 256 data set
was around 10,000 images only so you can
see that there's a huge several order
magnitude difference between the number
of parameters you need to learn and the
actual amount of content you can learn
that from but you use a lot more content
you can learn powerful features and
reuse that for other tasks and you can
see a huge jump not only from the state
of the art but a massive
jump from what you can get just training
on that data the other investigation we
did was to look at all the intermediate
layers not just the final softmax layer
we wanted to understand how how
important it was to train a very deep
model so we took the all the layers of
an image net model and we trained
different types of classifiers on top
hbm's and a soft max classifier so the
SVM starting from layer one was already
giving us about 25 percent accuracy by
layer 5 the last convolution layer it
was beating state-of-the-art by about 10
percent and Caltech 101 is another
variant of the same type of data it's
slightly easier task and then the just
to confirm we trade retry and soft max
classifiers and you can see that because
they're very similar models they're both
linear classifiers they get the same
type of results and this is essentially
very close to the results you saw on the
other graph so yeah in summary I showed
a way to understand what these powerful
models are doing and how to use them to
better understand how to improve the
performance of the models so thank you
and yeah clarify is always hiring
yep so you mentioned that bounty boxes
and things like brown mark complete by
this but it seems like you use it as
sort of a seed to grow that a bounding
box based on other yeah exactly that's
what that salient e paper actually tried
to do was not only get a blurry notion
of saline see but they tried to use
segmentation algorithms afterwards to
use the Saline C as a seed to those
algorithms and then really trace out the
objects and it worked pretty well one of
the challenges that started out of limit
amount of labels and a limited amount
trained with
it seems helpful to be able to go out to
some of these sites that have order to
classify data or to use the existing
models to classify and then retrain
based on larger stuff yeah it's
definitely possible I mean the problem
with aa so the question was there's a
lot of labeled data out there can we
utilize it and can we utilize a trained
model to help clean it up and I think
the answer is yes and it's varying
depending on how what source is coming
from different sources like social media
are very noisy but there's so much more
content there that the noise kind of
washes out if you train a big enough
model and for long enough but there's
also much cleaner sources and then
there's always manually billing which
you can do to get perfect sources
so the question was the lower layers
show a decent amount of performance and
classification and he was asking if we
use that in higher layers or near the
classification the final outputs of the
classifier we haven't tried that yet we
are working on a bunch of different
architectures but that's not one of them
I think there's a lot more information
in the higher layers just because
they've extracted it out so many more
times that feeding in very low level
information might hurt the
classification but different types of
information might help a lot
actually that's a good question so he
was pointing out that layer five with
SVM was performing better than layer
seven so layer 5 is last convolution
layer and layer seven is layer six was a
fully connected layer taking all the
information from that last convolution
layer and producing a 1 by 1 by K output
and layer 7 once again fully connected
so it could be that that collapsing lost
a bit of information but it's also a lot
different when you look at softmax it
didn't perform right it performed in a
way you'd expect where the fifth layer
is performing words and also in the
harder data set the ordering was kind of
consistent so it could be anomaly of
that SVM just getting good
initialization I don't know it could be
but it's it's not really consistent with
theory or kind of the rest of the
results because they're both doing
linear classifications essentially
there's some tricks with SVM's to make
them nonlinear but you can use different
nonlinearities and your neural nets as
well so in essence they're really doing
the same thing
so we do everything on GPUs kind of the
top-end GPUs you can buy and it's
crucial it gives literally a 30 times
speed up over CPUs so the question was
is it's training time becoming a
bottleneck I mean as we always get more
and more data and it's literally orders
of magnitude more data that we're
collecting it is becoming a bottleneck
but there's a lot of research going on
about parallelizing these networks and
it's kind of a at this point it's a
well-known problem of how to do that
it's not perfectly linear by any means
but it can definitely speed up the
training significantly so that's enough
in the roadmap of these
so we're doing all the programming on
the GPS with CUDA what we have
implemented a bunch of different ways
for different hardware but CUDA is the
main one we train on so we wrote
everything in-house C and Python yep
yeah so the question was about less
concrete classes like gloomy so it can
recognize a variety of different
categories we see blurr come out we see
abandoned come out very subtle things
that happen it images even fun or
together Ness which you see when people
are close together holding hands or
kissing that is recognized
yep you know you have different layers
box sizes are those swept are those
discrete of each other on a regional way
like when you pick a size sweeping the
whole entire thing pixel by pixel or is
it like so the question was how the
convolutions are applied over the image
and other layers so it depends on a
layer but it comes down to two
parameters one is the size of the filter
and one is a stride between where you
apply the filter so in lower layers we
do strides of two because there's so
much spatial content that we can't
compute it at every location is too
expensive so we do strike two so it
takes literally top corner picture pixel
and then skips one and then applies the
whole template at the next yeah yeah
because the filters are like 7 by 7 but
the stride is 2 so it was 5 overlap in
every case
unfortunately that's confidential yep
not yet but we've been talking to a lot
of people in the medical space about 3d
images and scans it's very interesting
and it could really help out in that
area yep
yeah I think you really want to go as
low as you can because you lose a lot of
information by skipping and you can see
that in some of the results from this
year's competition they did even lower
strides in the first couple layers and
it improved quite a bit there's a bunch
of new ideas introduced but I think that
was a really important one so as
regarding unsupervised learning in the
first few layers so we actually don't do
any unsupervised learning in this it's
all just taking random filters in all
the layers and training with the output
categories yeah so that's in our
vocabulary all these descriptive words
like abandoned or already baked into the
vocabulary